On February fourth a respawn
entertainment backed by EA released
someone no one expected apex legends a
very popular and unique addition to the
Battle Royale genre and finally a
breakthrough for the company respawn
respawn was responsible for the creation
of titanfall and titanfall 2 a super
underrated series of games that ran and
played well but died and fell off due to
bad errors from the developers the
titanfall was an Xbox exclusive with not
much happening and titanfall 2 released
to everyone but no one on ps4 or PC knew
that it was going to be available to
them and still thought it was an
exclusive that on top of the fact that
they released the game in between two
big heavy hitters like Call of Duty
infinite warfare and battlefield 1 and
the game was in trouble from the
beginning even though both games called
Duty infinite warfare and battlefield 1
were received pretty poorly people don't
have an unlimited supply of money so
they spent their money out to Call of
Duty and Battlefield hoping it would be
a smash hit
so the devs got to work on apex legends
not making a reskin but evolving the
game so much that even the behemoth of
the genre itself for tonight took some
ideas from it and are still used in game
today that's how big the impact was apex
had about 50 million players in the
first 6 weeks and any company making a
game would love to see their numbers for
the game they took so long to create
immediately following the game players
craved content this was most likely a
result from the majority of players
coming from fortnight where weekly
content was the Normand anything unlike
that was definitely not OK
apex didn't update much in between
release in season 1 but when season 1
came it definitely hit hard with a new
weapon a new battle pass and tons more
but it fell short loads of terrible
content within the battle paths like
stat trekkers voice lines filled
majority of the past leaving not much
room for skins and weapons and also
excluding some legends of skins entirely
like Pathfinder who received no skin
throughout the duration of the vetto
pass foreigner doesn't have to worry
since their game is in class base unlike
apex legends and they can release skins
when they want but apex should include
all characters with at least one skin to
hold them off and maybe give people the
incentive seeing all this gave players
like myself and no one's had to have to
grind in play and there was no
challenges claiming that the battle pass
was actually a lot harder to earn
without them characters were also very
unbalanced the Wraith had been
discovered to have the smallest tip box
in the game and pathfinders hitbox I
believe to this
is still bugged for his limbs allowing
you to not do any damage to them and the
bigger characters like Gibraltar and
caustic weren't worth playing but the
main reason was replayability the better
rail formula is very simple you drop in
and neither be the last one standing or
die trying' ad nauseam and that was all
we got for apex for about a month and a
half we got nothing for the season only
to be finally receiving a three-day XP
event for the Battle pass while welcomed
it wasn't anything special this had pro
players and casuals alike complaining
about the game and even had some pro
teams dropping their players entirely
because of the lack of content any
foreseeable future was not looking great
for these pro teams who of course have
to pay their players that are on their
team and somehow need to turn a profit
and seeing his apex didn't really host
too many tournaments it wasn't worth
keeping a full team for the game
thankfully at the very end we did get an
event called the legendary hunt and that
was a teaser for what was to come for
season 2 season 2 had launched with
loads of praise weeks before it even
released we had tons of teasers about
what was even going to come out the
battle past was now filled with more
weapons legend skins new skydive emotes
loading screens and music when dropping
as well as a new character Watson loads
of new map changes happening in the map
to keep it feel fresh like the
Leviathans that used to be on the
outskirts of the map now running around
the map in the once popular places that
people used to drop and now being
destroyed like cascades and bridges as
well as new locations like the cage to
replace them the battle pass was
undoubtedly the hugest upgrade by far
now instead of survival time there is no
challenges that can rotate daily or
weekly to complete whenever you feel
like most of them reward an entire rank
altogether and these challenges aren't
difficult if you played any game with a
battle past type challenge you're
completely familiar with the system go
to this location kill people in this
location headshots with this weapon
class etc etc the battle paths still had
those voice lines and trackers but they
ended up moving to the free versions to
make room for the affirmation music
packs emotes loading screens and new
legendary skins for caustic octane
Spitfire in the are 301 to put them in
the actual paid version on top of that
there is enough crafting materials in
the full battle pass granted you
complete all 100 tiers that you will get
yourself a legendary skin of your
choosing at the very end and there's
also enough apex coins to buy the
regular edition of the battle paths for
next season the regular edition cost a
thousand
tax coins are $10 and the premium is
2,800 or about $30 and you gain that
extra boost to where you started 25
immediately you'll beginning about 1200
plus crafting materials and 1000 a packs
coins and with these items and
challenges and makes the pass easier to
complete along you to not quit your job
drop out of school or be its
stay-at-home spouse just to even
complete this another addition was
ranked mode players can now test their
skill against similar players of their
skill range or if they just want a
challenge they can now play ranked this
one from bronze silver gold diamond
platinum and into apex predator this is
a very nice system everyone starts out
of bronze 4 and then climbs from there
at silver and up you have to spend RP to
play a game silver is won gold is to
diamond 3 platinum is for an apex
predator and be very highest as 5 per
game this had some intense gameplay
making you not just sit around to get
points for placement you can earn more
points for getting kills getting a
certain placement top 5 top 10 and top 3
and winning the match entirely with it
getting harder the more you climb since
you have to pay more and have to turn a
profit in order to keep going up the
ladder camping for placement is okay and
silver and maybe even gold but an apex
predator platinum and diamond do this
will be super challenging as players are
actually very skilled in those ranks and
are really looking for a fight and not
to hide if you're a solo player like
myself majority of the time you can
still queue with other players and
ranked allowing you to still climb
without the need of actual teammates to
communicate with but players have been a
team will succeed a lot more easily than
people who climb solo but it is still an
option as for balance bad weapons also
got received buffs in the form of hop
ups the alternator and the re 45 got a
hop up called disruptor rounds allowing
you to deal more damage to shield and
the Mozambique and the p20 20 got hammer
point rounds which is the opposite and
provides more health damage these were
so powerful that the alternator has
actually considered to be a top-tier
weapon even at the highest level of play
knocking a purple shield in about 4 hits
with the hop up other weapons like
energy weapons got extended mags to
increase the amount of ammo per magazine
as well and legends like Pathfinder and
Wraith due to their small hitbox or
buggy hitbox actually take more damage
per shot and I believe it's 5 to 10
percent while costigan Gibraltar their
damage reduction was now raised from 10%
15% along the to not take is much damage
because of their bigger hitbox and this
wasn't really a huge change but I feel
like that's an okay thing because it
wasn't completely one-sided and
overpowered for a certain character to
be playing with and I'm okay with that
it still allows you to play any
character that you like and succeed with
any character that you like which is
always nice about APEC seeing is we
don't have a huge roster this new season
sparked a lot more players interest
again including mine and having played a
lot more since release that's why I made
this video for the people who either
want to join for the first time or
returning players that maybe want to try
again and to that I say yes you should
return because these updates have been a
lot more positively received players are
returning and are happy to be back and
there's so much more to do with the game
now now seeing as the players are a lot
more consistent in playing it's only
right that the developers are a lot more
consistent in their game I mentioned way
back in the beginning of this video we
barely got anything during season 1 in
terms of new content after release and
so far an apex Legends season 2 we
haven't received another update but to
be fair it's only about day four of the
season so if we they realize input in
some content whether it be new outfits
weapons or balancing updates fixing the
current rosters of heroes and a bunch
more other stuff but as it says now
there isn't any update but hopefully in
the near future after this video is
uploaded we will be receiving some type
of new update the game feels fresh and
new but also still retains that Battle
Royale titanfall style so yes if you do
want to return go for it you're not
gonna be left behind or anything like
that and I can't force you to join and
come back but I'm just here to display
the facts about each season so you can
make a decision about returning or not
but based off my play time with Apex it
is definitely in a better place than
ever was before
yeah that's gonna be it for me I just
wanted to display the facts you guys can
make a decision about returning or not
with all the info laid out right in
front of you so you're not missing any
of it but yeah let me know in the
comments below what you guys are
involved in if you guys are a returning
player coming back already current
player that's just been playing or
you've dropped the game entirely let me
know in the comments below I'd love to
know your thoughts and why that's the
case yeah that's all the time we have
for today so like the V if you do enjoy
guys subscriber for new my two most
recent videos gonna be on screen if you
guys don't want to check that out that
guys hope it grows today thank you for
watching the video let me know like I
said if you've returned to apex or if
you officially cut it off from your
gaming day-to-day
and with that take care
[Music]
you